noël côté économique on sait déjà que la
console de jeu vidéo sera l'un des
cadeaux les plus offerts un foyer sur
trois ans possède une en france les
adultes autant que les enfants sont
désormais visés par les fabricants et la
concurrence est féroce roma mais si
emmanuel bec la guerre des trois aura
bien lieu trois consoles de jeux trois
raisons de choisir l'une plutôt que les
autres cette famille a dit oui à la wii
son charme
l'univers révolutionnaire d'un jeu tout
en mouvement cette fois que vous venez
de serveurs avoir un impact dans le jeu
pas comme les autres consoles mais pour
les accros des graphismes hyper réaliste
rien de tel que la xbox 360 et autant de
jeux à disposition peut avoir tous les
styles que ce soit la guerre la musique
les jeux de voitures entrent vraiment
notre bonheur est il y a les adeptes de
la playstation 3 une console multimédia
pour le jeu mais bien plus que cela en
revanche en fait une arme tout en un et
on peut tous avoir accès à internet
regarder des films en haute définition
avec le bourg r donc ça c'est absolument
génial
elle trône au centre des grands magasins
trois consoles de jeux vidéo sur un
marché qui rapporte plus que le cinéma
ou la musique 1,8 milliard d'euros en
france cette année en hausse de 12% et
la bataille commerciale fait rage à
l'échelle mondiale la wii mène la danse
avec près de 14 millions de consoles
vendues en un an seulement mieux que la
xbox sorti il y a deux ans dernière ni à
la traîne
la playstation fait profil bas mais mise
sur le long terme td je vous parlais de
guerre il faut attendre la fin de la
guerre pour compte éléments regarder ce
qui se passe
attendons 2030 12-13 2015 pour voir qui
sera le gagnant sur cette génération de
machines
une certitude à noël les consoles feront
partie des cadeaux les plus prisés au
pied du sapin un moment clé dans une
guerre parti pour durer